A skeleton walks into a bar. The bartender says, what do you have? And the skeleton says, I'll have a beer and a mop. All right, it's an old joke, but maybe you laughed at it. And if you did, why? What makes it funny? And what is it about puns that tickles are funny bone? Or dad jokes?
一个骷髅走进酒吧。酒保问：“你要点什么？”骷髅说：“给我来杯啤酒，再来把拖把。”好吧，这是个老笑话，但你可能笑了。如果你笑了，为什么呢？是什么让它变得好笑？双关语有什么特质能戳中我们的笑点？或者冷笑话呢？
How about practical jokes? Or even a person slipping on a banana peel? What could possibly tie all of these very different things together under the heading, humor. That's a question that's fascinated people for centuries and not just comedians. The writer E.B. White is supposed to have said that explaining a joke is like dissecting a frog. The thing dies in the process. But scientists and philosophers, undaunted, have nonetheless long tried to figure out what makes some things funny and other things not. Today, just in time for April Fool's Day, we'll explore that question and maybe help you figure out whether your practical joke is likely to soar or
恶作剧怎么样？甚至是一个人踩到香蕉皮滑倒？到底是什么能把这些截然不同的事物统一在“幽默”这个标题下？这个问题几个世纪以来一直让人们着迷，不仅仅是喜剧演员。作家E.B.怀特曾说，解释笑话就像解剖青蛙。在这个过程中，青蛙就死了。但科学家和哲学家们毫不气馁，长期以来一直试图弄清楚是什么让一些事情变得好笑，而另一些则不然。今天，恰逢愚人节，我们将探讨这个问题，并可能帮你判断你的恶作剧是会大获成功，还是
make people soar at you. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Peter McGraw, a marketing and psychology professor at the University of Colorado Boulder, and director of the humor research lab, also known as Hurl. He has spent more than a dozen years studying what makes things funny and has developed what he calls the benign violation theory that explains why people find humor in everything from tickling to puns. He's also explored humor on a more practical level, even trying his hand at stand-up comedy and hosting a podcast where he interviewed comedians about their lives and work.
让人对你大发雷霆。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的市场营销与心理学教授，也是幽默研究实验室（简称Hurl）的主任彼得·麦格劳博士。他花了十多年时间研究是什么让事物变得好笑，并提出了他所谓的“良性违规理论”，该理论解释了为什么人们从挠痒痒到双关语都能找到幽默感。他还从更实际的层面探索了幽默，甚至尝试过单口相声，并主持了一个播客，采访喜剧演员关于他们的生活和工作。
These days, he's exploring how people can apply lessons from comedy to become more innovative and creative thinkers in all areas of their life and work. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. McGraw. Kim, it's a great pleasure. That what a wonderful introduction. I actually feel good about myself right now. Oh, that's one thing that humor does for us, right? It makes us feel pretty good. Well, let's start by talking about how you got interested in studying the topic. What made you as a psychologist want to understand humor? One thing that's probably obvious, like most people, I greatly appreciate good comedy, whether it be consuming it, you know, going to a comedy club or watching a movie.
如今，他正在探索人们如何应用喜剧的经验教训，在生活和工作的各个领域成为更具创新性和创造力的思想家。感谢您今天加入我们，麦格劳博士。金，非常荣幸。多么精彩的介绍。我现在对自己感觉真好。哦，这就是幽默为我们做的一件事，对吧？它让我们感觉很好。好吧，让我们从你是如何对研究这个话题产生兴趣开始谈起。作为一名心理学家，是什么让你想要了解幽默？有一点可能是显而易见的，像大多数人一样，我非常欣赏好的喜剧，无论是消费它，比如去喜剧俱乐部还是看电影。
And then, you know, I would say by professorial standards, I got a kick out of trying to be funny in my professional life, but especially in my personal life. And yet, 10 years into my career at the time I stumbled on this question of what makes things funny, I had never even considered it as a worthy emotional phenomenon to study, to research. And part of it was no one else was doing that. It was, you know, it was running in the background a little bit of a niche kind of topic, interdisciplinary topic, one that, as you mentioned, goes back centuries, millennia, to some of the great scholars who psychological science, their ideas were built on. And I stumbled on this question in a very peculiar way. I was giving a talk at another university about what makes things wrong.
然后，你知道，我想说按照教授的标准，我在职业生涯中，尤其是在个人生活中，尝试变得幽默，并从中获得了乐趣。然而，在我职业生涯的第10年，当我偶然发现“是什么让事物变得好笑”这个问题时，我甚至从未考虑过将其作为一个值得研究的情感现象。部分原因是当时没有人这样做。你知道，它在后台运行，是一个有点小众的话题，一个跨学科的话题，正如你提到的，可以追溯到几个世纪、几千年前，追溯到心理科学所建立的那些伟大思想家。我以一种非常奇特的方式偶然发现了这个问题。当时我在另一所大学做关于“是什么让事情变得错误”的演讲。
I was studying moral psychology at the time. and because I want to be a good speaker, I used a kind of provocative, entertaining example of religious marketing that people might find wrong. And I got some laughs. And a hand went up in the back of the room. And I was asked the most important question of my professional life. Actually, maybe the most important question of my life. And this professor, she raised her hand. She just pointed out the incongruity between what I was saying and what was happening, which was I was saying that moral violence.
我当时正在研究道德心理学。因为我想成为一名优秀的演讲者，我使用了一个关于宗教营销的挑衅性、娱乐性的例子，人们可能会觉得这不对。我得到了一些笑声。教室后面举起了一只手。我被问到了我职业生涯中最重要的问题。实际上，也许是我一生中最重要的问题。这位教授举起手。她只是指出了我所说的和正在发生的事情之间的不协调，那就是我当时在说道德暴力。
cause anger and disgust, and then she rightfully pointed out, yet we're laughing. Why? And I stood there dumbfounded, and I went back to my university and I recruited a very bright graduate student, Caleb Warren. I said, we should answer this question. And, you know, as they say, the rest is history, or at least ongoing history. Well, then let's dive into the big question that I post in the introduction, which is, what makes something funny? And what is benign, violation theory, how can it help us answer that question? So, yeah, so this very bright graduate student, Caleb Warren, and I jumped into a more narrow question, which is what makes moral violations funny.
会导致愤怒和厌恶，然后她理所当然地指出，但我们却在笑。为什么？我站在那里目瞪口呆，回到大学后，我招募了一位非常聪明的研究生，凯莱布·沃伦。我说，我们应该回答这个问题。而且，正如他们所说，剩下的就是历史了，或者至少是正在进行的历史。好吧，那让我们深入探讨我在介绍中提出的那个大问题，即，是什么让某事变得好笑？什么是良性违规理论，它如何帮助我们回答这个问题？所以，是的，这位非常聪明的研究生凯莱布·沃伦和我跳进了一个更狭窄的问题，即是什么让道德违规变得好笑。
But in order to answer a question like that, you need a good theory. So I think the average person doesn't understand what the value of a theory is. And it's very simple, in my opinion. A good theory helps you answer questions. And so it doesn't have to be totally right. it just has to be good enough. And then a good theory will allow you then to make predictions about questions you, you haven't even considered yet.
但为了回答这样的问题，你需要一个好的理论。所以我认为普通人并不了解理论的价值。在我看来，这很简单。一个好的理论可以帮助你回答问题。所以它不一定完全正确，只要足够好就行。然后一个好的理论将允许你对你甚至还没有考虑过的问题做出预测。
And so we got started on this and our look at the literature was disappointing. So I did something I'm not proud of, Kim. I googled what makes things funny. That was my starting point. That's what my undergraduates do when I give it. them an assignment, you know? Like they just Google this. And what I found was, harkening all the way back to these Greek philosophers, Aristotle, Plato, and then other great thinkers, Emmanuel Kant, Thomas Hobbs, Sigmund Freud, frankly, people way, way smarter than me,
所以我们开始了这项工作，我们对文献的查阅令人失望。所以我做了一件我不引以为豪的事，金。我谷歌搜索了“是什么让事物变得好笑”。那是我的起点。这就是我的本科生在做作业时所做的，你知道吗？他们只是谷歌搜索这个。我发现的是，追溯到这些希腊哲学家，亚里士多德、柏拉图，然后是其他伟大的思想家，伊曼努尔·康德、托马斯·霍布斯、西格蒙德·弗洛伊德，坦率地说，比我聪明得多的人，
had put four theories of humor. And those theories take one of three flavors. They point out what we call superiority theory. We laugh at something that, We sort of laugh at the follies and foibles of others. Relief theory or release theory, which is humor is this kind of release of tension that we carry around all the time. Freud's responsible largely for that. And then the 800-pound gorilla of humor theories, incongruity theory. We laugh at some mismatch there. And what we realized, I think, very quickly, and the benefit of coming to it as I was approaching
提出了四种幽默理论。这些理论有三种风格。它们指出了我们所说的“优越理论”。我们嘲笑某事，我们嘲笑他人的愚蠢和怪癖。或者“缓解理论”或“释放理论”，即幽默是这种我们一直随身携带的紧张感的释放。弗洛伊德对此负有很大责任。然后是幽默理论中的“800磅大猩猩”，即“不协调理论”。我们嘲笑某种不匹配。而我们意识到，我认为，非常快，而且作为我接近职业生涯中期时接触到它的好处是，首先，我们需要三种幽默理论是不合理的，一个好的理论是所谓的“简约的”，对吧？它很简单。而且你不应该不得不从菜单中选择，比如，这个理论适用于闹剧，但那个理论适用于双关语。所以，我们发现了一篇由语言学家撰写的鲜为人知的论文，它成为了你所说的“良性违规理论”的基础。简而言之，我们发现的是，并且我们在Hurl中一次又一次地发现，人们之所以笑，之所以感到有趣，之所以判断某事好笑，是因为它同时是错误的但又没关系，具有威胁性但又安全，不合逻辑但又合乎逻辑。
mid-career was, it just, first of all, it didn't make sense that we need three theories of humor, that a good theory is what we call parsimonious, right? It's simple. And that you don't, you shouldn't have to select from a menu that, like, well, this theory works for Pratt Falls, but that theory works for puns. And so, uh, we found this sort of little known paper written by a linguist that served as the basis for, as you called it, the benign violation theory. And in short, what we found was, and we find time and time again in Hurl, is that people laugh at, they're amused by, they judge something as funny if it is simultaneously wrong yet okay, threatening yet safe, doesn't make sense yet makes sense.
所以你可以想象一个维恩图，良性和违规之间的重叠。发生的情况是，违规给了我们唤醒，让我们担心，然后我们所谓的“良性评估”，看到这如何是没关系的，翻转它并把它从坏变好。我们笑是为了告诉世界，这件看起来如此具有威胁性的事情实际上是无害的。在我忘记之前，那个让人们发笑的道德并置是什么？所以在这项研究中，我正在研究一些人如何发现宗教营销在道德上是应受谴责的，因为教会使用商业原则来拯救灵魂。他们只是觉得这很恶心。他们担心这可能会让你偏离宗教可能具有的正义。这个例子是佛罗里达州坦帕市的一家教会，它的初衷非常好。
So you can imagine kind of a then diagram, an overlap between benign and violation. And what happens is the violation gives us arousal, makes us concerned, and then what we call the benign appraisal, seeing how this is okay, flips it and turns it from bad to good. And we laugh to tell the world this thing that seems so threatening is actually harmless. Before I forget, what was that moral juxtaposition that made people laugh? So in this research, I was looking at how some people find religious marketing to be morally reprehensible for churches to use commercial principles to save souls. And they just find it icky. And they're concerned that it may take you away from the righteousness that religion may have. The example was a church in Tampa, Florida that had very good intentions.
那就是让人们去参加它的冬季静修会。你想拯救灵魂吗？让我们让人们去参加冬季静修会。所以他们决定举行抽奖。所以来参加冬季静修会，你就会被列入抽奖名单。人们觉得好笑的是大奖的选择。那是一辆黄色的悍马H-2 SUV。不是那种让人捧腹大笑的东西，但很好，足以让人会心一笑。带着它走上通往天堂的道路。我们发现的情况是，根据你对那是对还是错的看法，那个例子好笑与否。所以那些不太虔诚的学者与这个教会没有很强的联系等等，他们能够看到它如何同时是错误的和好笑的。那么你如何在实验室里研究幽默呢？你多年来做过哪些实验，我的意思是，我相信你不能告诉我们所有这些，
And that was to get people to go to its winter retreat. You want to save souls? Let's get people to the winter retreat. And so they decided to have a raffle. So come to the winter retreat, you get enrolled in the raffle. And what people found funny was the choice of grand prize. And that was a yellow H-2 Hummer SUV. Not exactly a gut buster, but good, but good for a chuckle. Take it on the road to paradise. And what we found to be the case was, depending on your perspective about how wrong or right that was, that example was funny or not. And so those academics who aren't very religious don't have a very strong connection to this church and so on, they were able to see how it was both wrong and funny at the same time. So how do you study humor in a lab? What are the experiments that you've done over, I mean, I'm sure you can't tell us all of them,
但也许是你多年来做过的几个帮助你制定理论并更好地理解是什么让事物变得好笑的实验。所以我给你举一个我认为更有趣的例子。所以很多，我承认，基本上就是给人们看有趣的图片或有趣的笑话，然后问他们，这有多好笑？你笑了吗？你觉得这冒犯人吗？你觉得这无聊吗？
but maybe a couple that you've done over the years that have helped you formulate the theory and better understand what makes things funny. So I'll give you an example of one of, I think, more, one of the more fun ones. So a lot of them, I admit, is just basically showing people funny images or funny jokes and then just asking them, how amusing is this? Did you laugh? Do you find this offensive? Do you find it boring?
顺便说一句，这是一组重要的问题。因为在我们做的任何要求某人做出判断的研究中，我们都会问三种风格的问题。一个是，你有多觉得有趣，对吧，触及那种幽默体验？我们问，你被冒犯了吗？如果是，程度如何？你觉得无聊吗？如果是，程度如何？原因是一个笑话可能以两种不同的方式失败。
And by the way, this is an important set of questions. because in any study we do that we ask someone a judgment, we ask three styles of questions. One is, how amused are you, right, getting at that experience of humor? We ask, are you offended? And if so, by how much? And are you bored? And if so, by how much? And the reason for that is a joke can fail in two different ways.
你提到了冷笑话。冷笑话，当它们不好笑时，很少会冒犯人。对吧？它们落在连续体的无聊一端。但有很多笑话非常大胆。当这些笑话失败时，人们会被冒犯。他们会感到愤怒。所以一个好的幽默理论不仅能够预测什么时候某事会变得好笑，
You mentioned dad jokes. Dad jokes, when they're not funny, are rarely ever offensive. Right? They fall on the boring side of the continuum. But there's a lot of jokes that are very risque. And when those jokes fail, people are offended. They're outraged. And so a good theory of humor is able to not only predict when something's going to be funny,
而且当它未能变得好笑时，它落在哪一边？所以我们总是问这些问题。但这个实验旨在测量微笑和笑声。我给你举一个例子。我们一直非常批评“不协调理论”，因为一方面不协调往往定义不明确，但人们通常会说，如果你问普通人，是什么让某事变得好笑？他们会说一些令人惊讶的事情。我们嘲笑令人惊讶的事情。而我们提出的论点是，实际上这对于幽默来说既不是必要的也不是充分的。
but also when it fails to be funny, which side does it fall on? So we always ask those questions. But this one was designed to measure smiling and laughter. And I'll give you an example from it. We've always been very critical of incongruity theory because one is oftentimes incongruity is not well defined, but oftentimes what people will say is, and if you ask the regular everyday person, what makes something funny? They'll say something surprising. We laugh at things that are surprising. And we make the argument that actually that's neither necessary nor sufficient for humor.
例如，我们嘲笑我们知道笑话结尾的笑话。也就是说，它们没有什么令人惊讶的。我重看了《我为玛丽狂》，你知道，它上映20、30年后。顺便说一句，仍然非常有趣，而且我知道所有的笑话。我发现自己笑了。所以在这项研究中，我们让我们的受试者与我们所谓的“同谋”进行对话，基本上是一名冒充学生的助理研究员。这是心理学研究中非常常见的技术。
For example, we laugh at jokes that we know the punchline to. that is there's nothing surprising about them. I rewatched there's something about Mary, you know, 20, 30 years after it came out. By the way, still very funny, and I know all the jokes. And I found myself laughing. So in this study, we had our subjects engaged in a conversation with what we call a Confederate, basically a research assistant who's posing as a student. This is a very common technique in psychological studies.
我们基本上在互动的某个时刻，那个人抓了一把彩虹糖扔向受试者，这看起来可能是一种侮辱性的行为。然而，在其中一个条件下，我们要么宣布，我要把这些彩虹糖扔向你，要么不宣布（你知道，或者没说他们要扔彩虹糖）。而在那个宣布了并扔了彩虹糖的条件下，实际上比不宣布时有更多的笑声。我们这样做是为了证明惊喜对于喜剧来说不是必要的，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？但那个实验中不太令人惊讶的条件实际上比令人惊讶的条件得到了更多的微笑和笑声。所以有一句谚语说，幽默是悲剧加时间。你写过关于什么时候对悲剧开玩笑还为时过早的文章。
And we basically at some point in the interaction, the person grabbed a handful of skittles and threw them at the subject, which might seem to be kind of an insulting thing to do. In one of the conditions, though, we either announced, I'm going to throw these skittles at you or I'm not, you know, or didn't say they were going to throw the skittles at them. And in that condition where they announced it and through the Skittles, there was actually more laughter than when not. And we did this to show that surprise is not necessary for comedy, right? You know what I mean? But the less surprising condition in that experiment was actually got more smiles and laughter than the surprising condition. So there's a saying that humor is tragedy plus time. And you've written about when it's too soon to joke about something tragic.
答案是什么？需要多长时间？在你回答之前，你能说我们什么时候才能在悲剧里找到幽默吗？我很高兴你问这个问题，因为我们进行了一项巨大的横断面研究来回答那个确切的问题。在描述研究之前，我要先说出结论。答案是时间的长短取决于很多事情，包括它是一个多大的违规。但我们，作为那项工作的结果，我们修正了“喜剧是悲剧加时间”的观点。改为“喜剧是悲剧加上适量的时间”。我会先凭直觉说。那就是有很多事情还为时过早。然后到某个时候，对它们开玩笑就变得可以接受了。
What is the answer? How long does it take? Can you say before we can find humor in tragedy? I'm glad you asked that question because we ran a huge cross-sectional study to answer that very question. I'm going to give away the punchline before I describe the study. And the answer is the amount of time depends on a lot of things, including how big a violation it is. But we, as a result of that work, we revised the idea that comedy is tragedy plus time. to be comedy is tragedy plus the right amount of time. And I'll lead with an intuition. And that is there's lots of things that are too soon. And then at some point it becomes okay to joke about them.
但在某个时候，足够的时间过去了，那件事就不再值得被开玩笑了。所以你得到的是，太早了会有愤怒，太晚了会无聊。而且，再次，那个甜蜜点，时间方面的峰值。为什么时间有助于让某事变得更好笑？嗯，因为时间的流逝创造了与它的距离。而距离，无论是时间的流逝、物理距离还是关系距离，都有助于通过消除它们的威胁将违规转化为良性违规。
But at some point, enough time passes that that thing is no longer worthy of being joked about. And so what you get is too soon has the outrage, too late is boring. And there's, again, that sweet spot, that peak in terms of time. Why is it the time helps make something funnier? Well, because the passage of time creates distance from it. And distance, whether it be the passage of time or physical distance or relational distance, helps turn violations into benign violations by removing their threat.
所以在那个研究中，我们测量了人们对卡特里娜飓风恶搞账号的反应。我们发现的是，当卡特里娜飓风在纽约大都会区造成严重破坏时，来自这个恶搞账号的笑话并不好笑。然后随着时间的流逝，
And so in that study, what we did was we measured people's reactions to a parity account of Hurricane Katrina. And what we found was, as Katrina was wreaking havoc on the New York metropolitan area, the jokes coming out of this parody account weren't funny. Then with the passage of time,
它们开始变得好笑且不那么冒犯人。然后进一步，几个月几个月后，那些笑话看起来不再相关了。它们很无聊。所以我记不清确切的日期了，但大约是卡特里娜飓风发生39天后，我们发现那些笑话达到了顶峰。当然，在某些情况下，它在一小时后达到顶峰。在某些情况下，它达到顶峰。世界上有些悲剧可能永远不会达到顶峰，因为开玩笑永远不会变得可以接受。对吧。那是我的下一个问题，即，有没有一些话题是永远不好笑的？嗯，你知道，我认为这取决于你和谁谈。我认为喜剧演员会说，如果一个笑话好笑，就没有“太早”这回事。我知道我有以色列朋友会讲大屠杀笑话。他们有一种非犹太人所没有的某种许可。所以那个问题揭示的是围绕研究幽默的难以置信的复杂性。
they started to become funny and less offensive. And then further, months and months later, those jokes no longer seem relevant. They were boring. And so I can't remember the exact date, but it was like 30,
这是人们没有研究它的部分原因，因为乍一看它看起来太神秘了。它看起来太难了。但正如你所知，作为一个重视科学的人，科学有能力将复杂的事物解释清楚。如果我们能绘制人类基因组图谱，我们就能弄清楚是什么让事物变得好笑。我们只需要做一个实验。什么被认为是好笑的，在国家或文化之间有多大差异？有没有普遍的笑话或普遍类型的幽默？所以，老实说，当谈到喜剧时，几乎没有什么东西是普遍的。
nine days after Hurricane Katrina, we found that those jokes peaked. Now, of course, in some cases, it peaks an hour later. In some cases, it peaks. And there are some tragedies in the world that may never peak because it never becomes okay to joke. Right. That was my next question, which is, are there some topics that are just never funny? Well, you know, I think it depends on who you talk to. I think a comic says there's no such thing as too soon if a joke is funny. I know I have Israeli friends who make Holocaust jokes. They have some sort of license that that non-Jewish people don't have. And so what that question reveals is the incredible complexity around studying humor.
但对此的解释是，正如我所说，一个好的理论解释谜题。而其中一个谜题是，为什么笑话失败的方式有两种，我们已经提到过了？它可能太良性了，或者它可能是太大的违规。但同样，同一个笑话怎么能让一个人笑，另一个人打哈欠，而另一个人愤怒地跺脚？至少从理论的角度来看，我们可以解释这一点。那就是什么是错误的，什么是可以的，什么是良性的，什么是违规的，取决于个人、观众的价值观、信仰、生活方式、他们喝了多少酒，他们所处的环境，对吧，无论是在喜剧俱乐部还是在教堂，当然，还有他们的文化。因为文化创造规范，文化创造规则，而很多喜剧打破了规则。所以这取决于你以那种方式重视和不重视什么规则。那么，什么可能是普遍的？最普遍的东西是肢体喜剧。也就是说，在个人层面上，像挠痒痒和打闹游戏这样的事情。我们知道这一点，因为非人类灵长类动物在打闹时会笑。
It's part of the reason that people haven't studied it because at first blush it seems so mysterious. It seems so difficult. But as you know, as someone who values science, science has the ability to take the complex and explain it. If we can map the human genome, we can figure out what makes things funny. We just need to have an experiment. How much does what's considered funny vary by country or culture? Are there universal jokes or universal type humor? So there's very little that's universal when it comes to comedy, to be honest.
甚至，这太令人震惊了，金，你可以在YouTube上输入“老鼠笑声”，你会发现老鼠被挠痒痒的视频，它们在做老鼠版的笑声。现在，当你把它带入喜剧世界时，我们能想到的最接近的就是你在介绍中提到的，踩到香蕉皮滑倒。对吧。其背后的原因是，当某人摔倒，从楼梯上摔下来或类似的事情时，那显然是一种违规。我们担心他们的安全，但如果其中有什么东西让它变得安全，也许他们站起来，拍拍身上的灰尘，看起来很困惑。也许有我们想让他从楼梯上摔下来的人，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？
But the explanation for this is, as I said, a good theory explains puzzles. And one of the puzzles is, why are there two ways that a joke can fail, which we've already alluded to? It could be too benign or it could be too much of a violation. But also, how can the same joke make one person laugh, another person yawn, and another person stomped their feet? with outrage. And at least from a theoretical standpoint, we can explain this. And that is what is wrong and what is okay, what is benign and what is a violation, depends on the individual, the audience members, values, beliefs, lifestyle, the number of
所以有这些不同的方式。现在，这是我们能达到的最接近的程度，因为没有文化规范。没有语言，这一切都与肢体游戏的想法相连。但正如你所知，并不是每个人都觉得闹剧很有趣。所以喜剧的普遍性确实有局限性。而且闹剧也是，如果你认识那个摔倒或闹剧的人，会比完全陌生人更好笑，对吧，因为你不知道那个人是否受伤了或者可能发生了什么。是的，这取决于情况。我的意思是，看，我喜欢我的朋友在楼梯上摔倒，但我不喜欢我的朋友从楼梯上摔下来。
drinks they've had, the context they're in, right, whether they're in a comedy club or in a church, and of course, their culture. because culture creates norms, culture creates rules, and a lot of comedy breaks rules. And so it depends on what rules you value and don't value in that way. Now, what is likely to be universal? The most universal thing is physical comedy. That is, on the individual level, things like tickling and play fighting. And we know this because non-human primates laugh when play fighting.
那么幽默感与更高的智力相关吗？在我看来，聪明人能听懂笑话，而那些可能没那么聪明的人……我甚至不确定我该如何定义它。那是完全开放的。但你能——我与此相关的另一个问题是，你能既聪明又完全没有幽默感吗？是的，两者都是。所以首先，当人们谈论幽默感时，我们应该——当人们谈论幽默感时，我们应该清楚。幽默感有两个方面。
Even, and this is mind-blowing Kim, you can type into YouTube, rat laughter, and you will find videos of rats being tickled and them doing the rat equivalent of laughing. Now, when you take this into the world of comedy, the closest we can come to is the classic, as you mentioned on the intro, slipping on a banana peel. Right. And the reason behind that is when someone falls, falls down a flight of stairs or something like that, that is obviously a violation. we're concerned for their safety, but if there's something about that that makes it safe, perhaps they get up and find dust themselves off and look perplexed. Maybe there's someone we want to fall down a flight of stairs, right? You know what I mean?
它们出人意料地不相关。也就是说，你让别人发笑的能力，以及你对别人试图让你发笑的反应而发笑的可能性。而已经完成的少量工作发现，这些事情出人意料地不相关，即一个可能非常擅长让别人发笑的人可能并不容易发笑，反之亦然。然而，当谈到喜剧的创作时，
And so there's these different ways. Now, that's as close as we come because there are no cultural norms. There is no language, and it all is connected to that idea of physical play. But as you know, not everybody finds Pratt Falls to be amusing. And so there are real limits to the universality of comedy. And Pratt Falls also, it's if you know the person who fell or had the Pratt fall is funnier, right, than if it's a total stranger where you don't know whether that person got heard or what might have happened. Yeah, it depends. I mean, look, I love it when my friends fall up a flight of stairs, but I don't like it when my friends fall down a flight of stairs.
你是对的。你的直觉绝对正确。聪明人比不那么聪明的人更好。我认为这说得通。一是智力与创造力相关，而创造力确实是这个过程的基础。聪明人对世界知识渊博。所以如果你想能够创作喜剧，很多喜剧是关于世界上正在发生的事情，你知道，在这个意义上。最后，它确实是，而且这不是我们到目前为止谈论的内容，但良性违规理论有第三个要素，那就是对错误和可以的判断必须同时发生。所以“机智”这个词确实是关于你如何同时将这些评估结合在一起。而那
So is a sense of humor correlated with higher intelligence? It just seems to me that smart people get jokes and people who are maybe not quite as intelligent. I'm not even sure how I'm defining that. That's wide open. But can you be – and my other question that's related to this is can you be intelligent and have no sense of humor? Yes and yes. So first of all, when people talk about a sense of humor, we should be – when people talk about a sense of humor, we should be clear. There's two sides of a sense of humor.
并不容易做到。我们知道大多数幽默尝试都失败了。我们知道大多数专业人士确实必须写很多很多的笑话才能找到那一个非常、非常好的笑话。所以聪明肯定有帮助。现在，我想明确一点，聪明并不一定是指传统意义上的获得高GRE或高SAT分数。当然。因为，你知道，我们经常有那种非常、非常擅长让别人发笑的班级小丑，可能在传统教育形式上并不出色，部分原因是他们是反规范的。他们不守规矩等等。所以真的，这不是关于毕业典礼致辞的学生，我实际上认为他们不是最有趣的人，对吧？是那些聪明，但也能够坐在这种空间里，愿意打破一些规则的人。毕业典礼致辞的学生
and they're surprisingly uncorrelated. That is, your ability to produce laughter in others and the likelihood that you laugh in response to someone's attempt to produce laughter in others. And the little work that's been done finds that those things are surprisingly uncorrelated, that someone who might be very good at making people laugh may not be very easy to laugh and vice versa. However, when it comes to the production of common,
非常擅长遵循规则。他们不太擅长打破规则。我认为这更像是那种有这种优势的创业型人才。你不久前发表了一篇关于幽默抱怨的论文，发现如果你有想抱怨的事情，以幽默的方式抱怨有优点也有缺点。你能谈谈那个吗？你发现了什么？我很乐意。我必须说那可能是我最喜欢的论文。我通过我声称我不抱怨事情的想法想到了那篇论文背后的想法，这完全是错误的。甚至不是，我抱怨
comedy, you are correct. Your intuition is absolutely correct. Smart people are better than less smart people. And that makes sense, I think. One is intelligence is correlated with creativity, and creativity really is at the foundation of this process. Smart people are knowledgeable about the world. And so if you want to be able to make comedy, a lot of comedy is about what's happening in the world, you know, in that sense. And then lastly, it really is, and this is not something we've talked about to this point, but there is a third element to the benign violation theory, and that is that judgment of wrong and okay has to occur simultaneously. And so that term being quick-witted really is about how do you bring those appraisals together at the same time. And that's
一直都在抱怨。你知道为什么吗？因为人类一直都在抱怨。人们一直都在抱怨。因为抱怨在某些方面是有用的，有时是虚假有用的。也就是说，我们有关于抱怨价值的理论。并非所有理论都是正确的。例如，抱怨实际上并没有像我们认为的那样通过宣泄来帮助我们。它确实有帮助，因为压抑抱怨真的很糟糕。压抑一种情绪往往会使它变得更糟。但有时人们抱怨是为了得到什么。有时他们抱怨是为了向世界展示他们有专业知识。
not easy to do. We know that most humor attempts fail. We know that most professionals really have to write lots and lots of jokes in order to find that one very, very good joke. And so being smart certainly helps. Now, I want to be clear, being smart is not in the traditional sense of getting high GREs or high SATs necessarily. Sure. Because, you know, we often have that class clown who is very, very good at making people laugh, may not actually excel in traditional forms of education, in part because they're counter-normative. They don't behave and so on. So really, it's not about the valedictorians I actually don't think are the funniest people, right? It's the people who are smart, but also can sit in this space where they're willing to break some rules. Valedictorians
所以我抱怨，哦，这个甜点，哦，太糟糕了。因为我想让世界知道，我知道好的食物是什么味道等等。但我发现我是个抱怨者，但我倾向于是一个幽默的抱怨者。我做了很多讽刺和尖刻的俏皮话，让人们对糟糕的天气、糟糕的交通、你知道，糟糕的甜点等等发笑。所以这说得通，对吧？抱怨是对负面事物的表达，而笑话是将负面事物转化为正面事物的一种方式。所以这项关于幽默抱怨的工作，凯莱布·沃伦也是那篇论文的合著者。所以我们发现人们喜欢幽默的抱怨者。
are very good at following rules. They're not very good at breaking rules. It's sort of more the entrepreneurial person, I think, who has that edge. You published a paper a little while ago on humorous complaining and found that if you have something you want to gripe about, that there are advantages and disadvantages to complaining in a funny way. Can you talk about that a little bit? What did you find? I'd be happy to. I have to say that might be my favorite paper. And I came to the idea behind that paper through, I caught my claiming that I don't complain about things, which is completely false. It's not even, I complain
幽默的抱怨很吸引注意力。人们会分享幽默的抱怨。所以如果你想抱怨一家公司，如果你想让它“病毒式传播”，幽默的抱怨很棒。幽默抱怨的缺点是它们不会激发我们通常想要的反应。如果你向室友抱怨水槽里的盘子，那可能会让他或她去洗盘子。但如果你对水槽里的盘子进行幽默的抱怨，你是在把这件错误的事情变得可以接受。因此，它可能不会激发你想要的补救行为。所以我说，你知道，根据你想要抱怨的结果选择你的武器。
all the time. You know why? Because humans complain all the time. People complain all the time. Because complaining in some ways is useful and sometimes falsely useful. That is we have theories about the value of complaining. Not all of them are correct. So for example, complaining actually doesn't help us through catharsis in the way that we think it does. It does help us because suppressing a complaint is really bad. Suppressing an emotion tends to make it worse. But sometimes people complain in order to get something. Sometimes they complain to show the world that they have expertise.
笑声和幽默之间的关系和区别是什么？我们嘲笑有趣的事情，但有紧张的笑声。有不舒服的笑声。那么笑声和幽默是如何相关的呢？所以我们发现情绪、愉悦、判断、好笑。所以你有情绪、认知，然后是行为、笑声，这是构成幽默体验的三个要素。它们不一定都必须存在，但当它们存在时，往往是一种更强烈的体验。现在，笑声确实，我认为，是最大的谜题，也是我认为最
So I complain, oh, this dessert, oh, it's terrible. Because I want the world to know, I know what good food tastes like and so on. But what I found was I am a complainer, but I tend to be a humorous complainer. I make a lot of like sarcastic and weedy quips to make people laugh about the bad weather, the bad traffic, you know, a bad dessert and so on and so forth. And so this makes sense, right? A complaint is an expression of something negative and a joke is a way to take something negative and make it positive. And so this work on humorous complaining, Caleb Warren was a co-author on that paper also. So what we found was people like humorous complainers.
困难的，部分原因是人们在有他人在场时更有可能笑，在没有他人在场时不太可能笑，对吧？因为没有什么可交流的。笑声可以伪装，对吧？所以任何有过老板的人都知道，你可以伪装笑声，对吧？是的。是的。而且笑声可以被压抑。也就是说，有人讲了一个你觉得好笑的下流笑话，但你不想让世界知道你觉得那很好笑。所以你可以抑制、抑制笑声。所以，但笑声，正如我所说，起到了这种交流功能。我们知道它确实如此，因为我们在那些没有能力像人类那样表达思想的物种中看到了它。所以我发现这是一个非常有趣的
Humorous complaints are attention getting. People will share humorous complaints. So if you want to complain about a company, a humorous complaint is great if you want it to, quote, unquote, go viral. The downside of humorous complaints are they don't spur the kind of reaction we often want them to. If you complain to your roommate about the dishes in the sink, that may get him or her to clean the dishes. But if you make humorous complaints about the dishes in the sink, you're taking this thing that's wrong and making it okay. And so as a result, it may not spur the kind of remedial behavior that you want in that sense. And so what I say is, you know, pick your weapon depending on which are the outcomes that you want for a complaint.
所有这些的要素。但同样，最好、最有趣的事情，你捧腹大笑，你得到那种积极、愉悦的感觉，然后你说，金，那太搞笑了。这让我想到了关于动物和幽默感的问题，因为我们认为有些动物有时在做的事情，你提到了老鼠，它们在笑，而且我认为我们已经在一些我们更亲近的亲属中认识到了这一点。但还有哪些动物有幽默感？我们怎么知道？
What is the relationship and the difference, say, between laughter and humor? We laugh at funny things, but there's nervous laugh. There's uncomfortable laughter. So how are laughter and humor related? So we find that the emotion, amusement, the judgment, funny. So you have emotion, cognition, and then behavior, laughter, are the three elements that make up a humorous experience. They don't all have to be present, but when they are, it tends to be a more intense experience. Now, laughter is really, I think, the sort of biggest puzzle and the one that I think is most
嗯，你知道，这个问题是完全开放的。不容易回答。大部分工作都是用，你知道，黑猩猩、倭黑猩猩、猴子、猿类等完成的。研究人员不称其为笑声本身。他们称之为“游戏喘息”。这与此相关。真的，喜剧的根源在于
difficult, in part because people are more likely to laugh when others are present, less likely to laugh when no one else is present, right? Because there's nothing to communicate. Laughter can be faked, right? So anybody who's had a boss knows that you can fake laughter, right? Yep. Yep. And laughter can be suppressed. That is, someone tells an off-collar joke that you think is funny, but you don't want the world to know that you think that's funny. And so you can stifle, stifle laughter. And so, but laughter, again, as I said, serves this communication function. And we know it does because we see it in species that don't have the ability to articulate ideas in the same way that humans can. And so I find that to be a really interesting
游戏。而游戏喘息，这真的很迷人，你知道，再次，是这种类似的声音。研究表明，在基因上与人类最接近的灵长类动物
element to all of this. But again, the best, most funny things, you bust a gut, you get that positive, delightful feeling, and you go, Kim, that was hilarious. That takes me to the question about animals and a sense of humor, because we think that what some animals are doing sometimes, and you mention rats, that they're laughing, and I think we have recognized it in some, some of our closer relatives. But what other animals have a sense of humor? And how do we know? it? Well, you know, this question is wide open. It's not easy to answer. The most of the work has been done with, you know, chimps, bonobos, monkeys, apes, and so on. The researchers don't call it laughter per se. They call it play panting. And this is connected. Really, the roots of comedy are in
与人类最接近的灵长类动物的游戏喘息与我们笑的方式最相似。对吧。所以我们知道它们是相连的。现在，马克·贝科夫是动物专家，尤其是狗的专家，有新兴的研究表明狗有幽默感，狗会笑。现在，任何养狗的人都会说，绝对，对吧？我的狗有幽默感。我的狗，引用一下，会笑，你知道，尤其是在玩耍时。猫主人，没那么多。所以很难知道。
play. And play panting, which is really fascinating, you know, again, is this sort of like kind of sound. And what the research shows is that the primates that are closest to humans genetically
不过，我对这个问题的感觉是，任何哺乳动物，在其剧目中，任何与自己物种进行游戏的哺乳动物，都有类似于幽默的情感体验。但同样，这项工作还没有完成。这是一个基于已经完成的工作和我所依赖的理论的预测。我认为猫会笑，但我们听不到。我的意思是，它们肯定在嘲笑我们。那是真的。我认为它们在嘲笑它们是如何在这个世界上占便宜的。是的。你在商学院教书，你最近的书叫《坚持商业》，是关于喜剧的经验教训如何帮助人们的工作生活。你能谈谈那个吗？
closest to humans have play panting that is most akin to the way we laugh. Right. So we know that they are connected. Now, Mark Bekhov is an expert
我们应该还是不应该尝试在工作中变得幽默？我过去认为我们应该，现在我认为只有我们中的一些人应该。所以，我会为为什么我们不应该都尝试在工作中变得更幽默提出简单的理由。那就是那个人。你知道那个人，那个认为自己很幽默的人，你知道。所以如果我告诉每个人去
in animals and especially an expert in dogs and there is emerging work that suggests that dogs have a sense of humor, the dogs laugh. Now, anybody who's a dog owner will say, absolutely, right? My dog has a sense of humor. My dog, quote, unquote, laughs, you know, especially when playing. Cat owners, not so much. So it's hard to know.
去在工作中变得幽默，我们真的得担心那个人，你知道我的意思吗？他就像，哦，是的，这是我的机会，你知道，因为糟糕的喜剧可能会，你知道，往好了说让人无聊，往坏了说冒犯人。工作场所是一个我们
My feeling about this, though, is that any mammal has some, in its repertoire, any mammal, that engages in play with its own species has something akin to humor as an emotional experience. But again, the work hasn't been done. This is a projection based upon what's been done and the theory I rely on. I think cats laugh, but we can't hear it. I mean, they certainly laugh at us. That's true. I think they laugh on how they're getting over on the world. Yes. You teach at a business school, and your most recent book is called Stick to Business, which is about how lessons from comedy can help people in their work lives. Can you talk about that?
应该包容的地方，你知道，它应该是一个让每个人都感到受欢迎和舒适的地方。所以我改变了我的想法，这是每个人都应该做的事情，那就是“幽默地思考”。所以正如你在开头提到的，我尝试过单口相声。我上过即兴表演课。我甚至开发了一个现场喜剧节目。所以我涉足了专业世界。
And should we or shouldn't we try to be funny at work? I used to think we should, and now I think only some of us should. So, and I'll make the easy case for why we all should not try to be funnier at work. And it's that guy. you know the guy the guy who thinks he's funny you know and so if I tell everybody to go
我意识到在那个世界里取得成功是极其困难的。然而，那些在那个世界里成功的人，不仅在天生和直觉上非常有创造力，而且还有一些技巧和窍门，有一些他们用来让事情变得更好笑的实践和观点。正是这些实践和观点，我们可以用来不是为了创作喜剧，而是为了创作可以帮助我们生活的创造性或创新性的事物。所以我给你举一个简单的例子。喜剧101，如果你还没有直觉地知道它，作为喜剧演员你学到的第一课，就是我所谓的“反转”或“逆转”。那就是产生一个对立的观点。我将用一个
go forth and be funny at work we got to really worry about that guy you know what I mean he's like oh yeah here's my chance you know and because bad comedy may you know at best case bore people at worst case offend people the workplace is a place that we
亨尼·扬曼的笑话来演示它，他是单句笑话之王。亨尼·扬曼说，当我读到喝酒的危险时，我放弃了。金，你认为亨尼在读到危险时放弃了什么？他放弃了阅读。他放弃了阅读。完全正确。是的。对吧？所以他做了你可能预料到的相反的事情。但，你知道，这使得那种违规变得良性，因为我们知道亨尼喜欢喝酒。你知道，我不想放弃喝酒，所以我放弃阅读。嗯，那些反转和逆转可以是，正如我刚才演示的那样，一个笑话的结尾，但它也可以是一个喜剧片段的前提。所以艾米·舒默的电影《生活残骸》是一部反转的浪漫喜剧。
should be inclusive you know and it should be one where everybody feel welcome and comfortable And so what I have pivoted my thinking is is something that everybody should do, which is to think funny. And so as you mentioned at the beginning, I've tried my hand at stand up. I've taken improv classes. I even developed a live comedy show. And so I've dipped my toe into the professional world.
所以典型的浪漫喜剧，男孩遇见女孩，男孩失去女孩，男孩追回女孩。在《生活残骸》中，恰恰相反。女孩遇见男孩，女孩失去男孩，女孩追回男孩，对吧？嗯，你可以找到反转。在现实世界中，它通常是一种打破非常疲惫的现状式思维的有用方式。我给你举一个这方面的简单例子。想象你是两个在布鲁克林的创业者，你正寻求在智能手机市场上挑战苹果和三星。你如何智胜苹果和三星？工程师团队领先你多年，嗯，这些家伙所做的是他们反转了
And what I've realized is it's incredibly difficult to be successful in that world. Yet those people who are successful in that world, not only, are they incredibly creative sort of innately and intuitively, but there are tips and tricks, there are practices and perspectives that they use to make things funnier. And it's those practices and perspectives that we can use not to make comedy, but to make things that are creative or innovative that can help our lives. So I'll give you a quick example. Comedy 101, the first lesson you learn as a comedian, if you don't already intuitively know it, is what I call reverse it or the reversal. And that's to produce an opposing perspective. I'll demonstrate it with a
我意识到，在那个世界里取得成功极其困难。然而，那些在那个世界里成功的人，不仅天生具有极强的创造力，而且他们还运用一些技巧、窍门、实践和视角来让事物变得更有趣。正是这些实践和视角，我们不仅可以用来创作喜剧，还可以用来创造那些具有创新性的事物，从而改善我们的生活。我举个简单的例子。喜剧入门的第一课，如果你还没有直觉的话，就是我所说的“反转”。也就是提出一个相反的观点。我用一个例子来演示一下。
joke by Henny Youngman, the king of the one-liners. Henny Youngman said when I read about the dangers of drinking, I gave up. Kim, what do you think that Henny gave up when he read about the danger? He gave up reading. He gave up reading. Exactly. Yes. Right. So he did the opposite of what you might expect there. But it, you know, that makes that violation benign because we know Henny likes to drink. You know, I don't want to give up drinking, so I'll give up reading. Well, those reversals and reversals can be, as I just demonstrated there, the punchline to a joke, but it could also be a premise to a comedy bit. So the movie Train Rec with Amy Schumer is a reverse rom-com.
亨尼·扬曼（Henny Youngman）的笑话，他是单口相声之王。亨尼·扬曼说：“当我读到饮酒的危害时，我放弃了。”金，你觉得亨尼读到危害时放弃了什么？他放弃了阅读。他放弃了阅读。没错。是的。对吧。所以他做了和你预期相反的事情。但这让这种违背常理变得无害，因为我们知道亨尼喜欢喝酒。你知道，我不想放弃喝酒，所以我放弃阅读。好吧，这些反转正如我刚才演示的那样，可以是一个笑话的包袱，也可以是喜剧段子的前提。比如艾米·舒默主演的电影《生活残骸》就是一部反转的浪漫喜剧。
So the typical rom-com, boy meets girl, boy loses girl, boy gets girl back. In Train Rec, it's the opposite. Girl meets boy, girl loses boy, girl gets boy back, right? Well, you can find the reversal. in the real world, and it's often a useful way to break out of very kind of tired status quo style thinking. I'll give you one quick example of this. Imagine your two entrepreneurs based in Brooklyn, and you're looking to take on Apple and Samsung in the smartphone market. How do you outsmart Apple and Samsung? Teams of engineers years and years ahead of you, well, what these guys did was they reversed
典型的浪漫喜剧是男孩遇见女孩，男孩失去女孩，男孩追回女孩。而在《生活残骸》中，情况恰恰相反：女孩遇见男孩，女孩失去男孩，女孩追回男孩，对吧？其实，你可以在现实世界中找到这种反转，这通常是打破陈旧现状思维的一种有效方式。我举一个简单的例子。想象一下，你们是两位在布鲁克林创业的企业家，想要在智能手机市场上挑战苹果和三星。你如何智胜苹果和三星？他们拥有领先你多年的工程师团队，而这些人所做的就是反其道而行之。
it. They didn't create a smartphone. They created the dumb phone. Right? So a phone that is made for people who want to be not more connected, but rather less connected. And so they've been able to stand out in the marketplace by thinking in reverse. And so I invite people to think in reverse, especially when they're stuck on a problem. There's been quite a bit of psychological research into who's funnier, men or women. And of course, as a woman, I have a point of view here, but I'm going to ask you, what's the answer to that? I mean, I know there was a recent pretty big meta-analysis that concluded that it's men, but then there's other research that says no. Is the jury still out? I think from a data standpoint, the jury is still out. There's a lot of work that needs to be done.
它们。它们创造的不是智能手机，而是“笨手机”。对吧？所以，这是一款为那些不想变得更“互联”，反而想减少“互联”的人们所设计的手机。因此，它们通过逆向思维在市场上脱颖而出。所以我邀请人们进行逆向思考，尤其是在遇到难题时。关于男性和女性谁更幽默，心理学界已经进行了不少研究。当然，作为一名女性，我对此有自己的看法，但我还是想问你，答案是什么？我知道最近有一项相当大规模的荟萃分析得出结论说是男性，但也有其他研究持不同意见。目前还没有定论吗？我认为从数据角度来看，目前还没有定论。还有很多工作需要做。
I think it's the wrong question, though. I'll be really honest. I think a lot of the work on gender that compares men and women, fails to recognize that men and women are more alike than they are different. And so, knowing whether someone is a man or a woman and predicting whether they're going to be funny or not is less important than knowing a whole bunch of other things about them. I'll give you the little work that I've done is, first of all, all of that work is very limited because there are an infinite number of ways to make comedy. If you choose one way to make comedy, for example, writing funny captions for cartoons,
但我认为这是一个错误的问题。说实话，我认为很多关于性别、比较男性和女性的研究，都未能认识到男性和女性的相似之处远多于差异。因此，了解一个人是男性还是女性，并据此预测他是否幽默，远不如了解关于他的其他许多信息重要。我做过一点点研究，首先，所有这些研究都非常局限，因为创造喜剧的方法有无数种。如果你选择一种创造喜剧的方式，例如，为卡通片写有趣的标题，
that may tell you that men are better or women are better at making captions for cartoons funny, but it doesn't explain the vast array that people make things funny, quips, satire, irony, Pratt Falls, etc. Also, all of that work doesn't, do what I think needs to be done is to look at how those jokes fail. And I'll give you an example of a little pilot study I ran. It's not worthy of publication, but I thought it was enlightening. I did this with my class where I had students doing exactly that, basically making jokes.
这可能告诉你男性或女性在为卡通片写有趣标题方面更胜一筹，但这并不能解释人们制造幽默的广泛方式，比如俏皮话、讽刺、反讽、滑稽跌倒等等。此外，所有这些研究都没有做我认为需要做的事情，那就是观察这些笑话是如何“失败”的。我给你举一个我做过的小型试点研究的例子。它虽然不值得发表，但我认为很有启发性。我是在我的课堂上做的，让学生们做完全相同的事情，基本上就是编笑话。
And then when we measured the funniness of these jokes and we compared men and women, we found that men's jokes tended to be on average slightly funnier than women's. So consistent with the existing research. However, we also measured how offensive the jokes were. And guess what? The men's jokes were also when they failed more likely to be offensive. And so any good study that compares men and women, which I don't think is that interesting a question, frankly, because I think there are funny men and there are funny women and they're not funny men and they're not funny women. but any research has to measure how are you failing because the failure part of it is as important as part of the success part of it. And so what my hunch is, I can't, you know, I haven't written
然后，当我们衡量这些笑话的幽默程度并比较男性和女性时，我们发现男性的笑话平均比女性的稍微好笑一点。这与现有研究一致。然而，我们也衡量了这些笑话的冒犯程度。你猜怎么着？男性的笑话在失败时也更有可能具有冒犯性。因此，任何比较男性和女性的优秀研究——坦率地说，我认为这并不是一个有趣的问题，因为我认为有幽默的男性，也有幽默的女性，有不幽默的男性，也有不幽默的女性——但任何研究都必须衡量你是如何“失败”的，因为失败的部分和成功的部分一样重要。所以我的直觉是，我还没写
the papers yet, but my hunch is that depending on how you look at the question, the answer is yes. Okay. You mentioned offensive jokes, and I'm going to venture into the question. a politically incorrect department now and ask, why does it seem that every culture have what we in the U.S. call Polish jokes or dumb blonde jokes? And what I'm talking about, of course, is the jokes that denigrate a particular group of people for their supposed lack of intelligence. Indeed, that seems to be a universal. Christy Davies, who was at the University of Reading, has done a lot of work on this. It's really fascinating work, qualitative research, mostly. And essentially the reason for that is that comedy can be used as a tool.
论文，但我的直觉是，取决于你如何看待这个问题，答案是肯定的。好的。你提到了冒犯性的笑话，我现在要冒险进入一个政治不正确的领域，问一下，为什么似乎每个文化都有我们美国人所说的“波兰笑话”或“金发女郎笑话”？当然，我指的是那些贬低特定群体智力水平的笑话。事实上，这似乎是一个普遍现象。曾在雷丁大学任教的克里斯蒂·戴维斯对此做了大量研究。这确实是非常迷人的研究，主要是定性研究。本质上，原因在于喜剧可以被用作一种工具。
So it can be used as a tool to entertain. As we've talked about with humorous complaining, it can be used as a tool to get people to like you, to garner attention. But it also can be used as a tool to critique the powerful or to critique the weak to punch up or punch down, so to speak. And that's that idea of punching down in terms of making fun of someone's intelligence due to some stereotype, some existing prejudice, is clearly punching down. And really, it's just designed, I think, twofold. One is to make the joke teller feel superior, hence that form of theory that has existed for such a long time.
所以它可以被用作娱乐工具。正如我们讨论过的幽默抱怨一样，它可以被用作一种让人喜欢你、博取关注的工具。但它也可以被用作一种批评强者或批评弱者的工具，也就是所谓的“向上攻击”或“向下攻击”。而那种基于某种刻板印象、某种现有偏见来嘲笑某人智力的“向下攻击”，显然就是向下攻击。而且我认为，它实际上有两个目的。一是让讲笑话的人感到优越，这就是那种存在已久的理论。
And then it's also just used as a tool to keep those differences in play. to continue to marginalize and to discriminate and to prejudice. And so I believe that the best comedy, I'm not speaking as a researcher, I'm speaking as a human, that the best comedy punches up. It takes on the powerful, and it looks to make the world a better place as a result of that. And I think that the best comedy,
然后它也被用作一种维持这些差异的工具，继续边缘化、歧视和偏见。所以我相信最好的喜剧——我不是以研究者的身份，而是以一个人的身份来说——最好的喜剧是“向上攻击”。它挑战强者，并试图以此让世界变得更美好。我认为最好的喜剧，
when it's looking down, is designed to draw people up. And so I, you know, I think the good communication, Comedians recognize that it is completely inappropriate to make jokes about homosexuals, but it's appropriate to make jokes about homophobes and a way to write a wrong, so to speak. Well, I'm going to put you on the spot, which really probably isn't asking you questions as a researcher, but just as a guy who's interested in humor. What's your favorite joke? Do you have a favorite comedian, your favorite funny movie?
当它向下看时，是为了提升人们。所以我认为，优秀的沟通者、喜剧演员认识到，拿同性恋者开玩笑是完全不恰当的，但拿恐同者开玩笑是恰当的，这是一种纠正错误的方式。好吧，我要让你当场出丑，这可能不是作为研究者问你的问题，而只是作为一个对幽默感兴趣的人。你最喜欢的笑话是什么？你有最喜欢的喜剧演员或最喜欢的喜剧电影吗？
Well, you know, that's a tough question because it's constantly changing. We can try this. This may not work well for a podcast, but you can edit it out if it doesn't work. Why don't we do one of my favorite jokes? All right. Okay. Go for it. So Kim, I want you to ask me, what is the secret to good comedy?
嗯，你知道，这是一个很难回答的问题，因为它一直在变。我们可以试试这个。这对于播客来说可能效果不好，但如果不行你可以剪掉。我们为什么不讲一个我最喜欢的笑话呢？好的。没问题。开始吧。那么，Kim，我想让你问我，好喜剧的秘诀是什么？
I know this joke. What is the secret to good comedy? Timing. I knew you were going to do that. that. And as you demonstrated, an old joke and I still laugh at it, right? They knew it was coming and it was still funny. That's right.
我知道这个笑话。好喜剧的秘诀是什么？时机。我就知道你会这么做。正如你所展示的，这是一个老笑话，但我仍然觉得好笑，对吧？他们知道笑话要来了，但它依然好笑。没错。
You know, in terms of favorite comedians, I don't want to pick just one, you know, in part because comedy rewards novelty, you know, so it's easy to fall in love with a new comic. But I'm living in Los Angeles right now. And last night, I had a wonderful, what felt like pre-pandemic experience. I dined outside and had a lovely dinner. And the gentleman at the table to my left, I look up, he signs the check, walks by me, I hear him say something, and I go, I know that voice.
你知道，关于最喜欢的喜剧演员，我不想只选一个，部分原因是喜剧奖励新奇感，所以很容易爱上一个新的喜剧演员。但我现在住在洛杉矶。昨晚，我经历了一次美妙的、感觉像是疫情前的体验。我在户外用餐，吃了一顿愉快的晚餐。我左手边桌子上的那位男士，我抬头一看，他签了单，从我身边走过，我听到他说了一些话，我心想，我认得那个声音。
And it was one of my favorite comedians. I had a Chris Rock sighting last night, which was nearly as delightful as my meal. Oh, that's a good story. Well, thank you. And thank you for joining us today, Dr. McGraw, if I dare say it's been a real riot talking to you. It's been my pleasure. Thank you, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
那是我最喜欢的喜剧演员之一。昨晚我偶遇了克里斯·洛克，这和我那顿饭一样令人愉快。哦，那是个好故事。好吧，谢谢你。也感谢你今天加入我们，麦格劳博士，如果我敢说的话，和你交谈真是太有趣了。这是我的荣幸。谢谢你，Kim。你可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speaking of psychology，连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Winerman 制作。我们的音效编辑是 Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。